5 46 on your wednesday morning hey
here's a heads up on an east valley
project that may drive you crazy
for a year and a half nevada department
of transportation announcing plans to
repave
nellis from tropicana on the south all
the way up to craig road
that is a 10 mile stretch no word about
which end of knellers are going to start
to work on but it is tentatively
scheduled to get underway
in late november stretching all the way
to the middle of 2022. it's a 26 million
dollar project it'll also include
upgrades in some of the major streets
that cross nellis
sahara charleston bonanza now drivers
you'll have at least
two lanes in each direction during the
work day but only one lane from eight at
night till six in the morning sundays
through fridays i expect we're going to
talk more about this as the work gets
closer with plenty of reminders once it
kicks into gear and all of this
information is on our website
8newsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving me crazy email me with pictures
and video please
to traffic eight at eight newsnow dot
com